pensate di ragazzi benvenuti a questo
video sono di mezzo ci siamo su chiamata
e mattina sono gitando questo video di
mattina prima di fare colazione cioè per
dire la domenica mattina ormai diventata
una roba tipo è più il colazione
certamente fa parte della mia giornata
pensato mi sto messo male nella vita
però ragazzi portiamo la bei rock swing
di prima mattina no è rega è di non mi
fai incazzati prima mattina che sono
metro da dove come ok che mattina la
sveglia e poi ragazzi ogni tanto ci
pensa ma non è mattina pure questi
cristiani quindi di happy pensare che
devono mettersi a pacchi e voglia
charlie fire of swing di mattina di
domenica bello perfetto ho capito che
oggi non è giornata legati a partiti che
merda complimenti
ma è andata bene che è finito il livello
perché sono dolori fermato tutto e non
ci avevo voglia ma finisse in fossimo
affermi che sono sul telefono questa no
perché io ciò il sound board di just do
it che quando clicchi una frase tipo non
lo so sweet vivo la mia vita al meglio
ogni giorno ma per ragazzi a parte
questa cagata non finisse in posti come
posso andarci non morendo ma che
potrebbe perfetto comprime la miglior
morte negli ultimi episodi ragazzo
convinto ci prova lega me lo sento
e vabbè dai tenace
le vittorie a google più youtube cazzo
vuol dire la madonna che bella pagina
famiglia cercare la vj red did not a
scrivere io ho scritto fa vj e fratte
prole posso cliccar e poi il prossimo
cliccare sullo ius cosa cazzo c'entra
non c'è ma mi cliccare youtube youtube è
una riproduzione di youtube un po strana
prefiggo piano jazz playlist l'hit
collaboration bellissimo su di green
cars ha pubblicato qualcosa è successo
se questo modo invito di esseri umani
ragazzi io sono convinto che quelli non
siano piedi che posso questa convinzione
è dentro poi non usciamo dai perché è
una cosa orribile
apprezzo l'impegno a parte per i piedi
delle persone però per il resto apprezzo
ultimate fighting streng bello alla
forte lui velocità media forza media e
vabbè mica quest'assise fine ecco a me
non vale so che sta bene [ __ ] io vivo
sono vivo brutta stronza vai vai vai
veloce veloce veloce ninja maledetto per
te solo seggiolino mai zio alla madonna
è svenuto e tenuto a caso è bene va bene
va bene va bene questo mi sa che è
abbastanza grosso non so seguiva perciò
mi inchino alla tua supremazia veramente
non ce la posso farlo anche un traguardo
davvero tutti i giorni mi capita che non
sa che si incastri nella mia bici laser
shooter e vabbè vi prego ragazzi canzoni
di major lazer qua sotto mentre avanti
il livello
ed è così che si passa a domenica
mattina sono ancora in voga che fossimo
l'hanno fatto granier impossible
quanta roba quanti impossible oggi
perché queste star o la minecraft
sinistra
ero brain sipro dovete stare calmi ma ma
calmi proprio come lo finisco livello ma
tu che salta ho fatto cio riprovare
fermi è vecchia ma do
ragazzi non ce la farò mai più a fare un
salto del genere va bene dall'aprire
ixtreme cos'è sta roba ma dio mio
ma cos'era con il prossimo e 99 per
cento tutti imposti con un secondo ce ne
sono un miliardo se ce la fai sei una
bestia subito non ci posso credere che
botta di culo incredibile 98 che questo
è l'ultimo poi mi chiamo foglio fatto
veramente tutti esposti grazie ciaia to
seek amy dalla motivazione sciaia miac
in questo mi ha detto che era possibile
e ci provo zio jolo irap deakes cosa
devo prendere j ax macro mi spiega che
senso è bello j ax dove sono sei proprio
qua j ax però
lights out renon questo bello ho mica un
livello fatto bene non ci posso credere
come te brutto stop e lucio sveglia una
sveglia rotta una tazza textbook un
orologio che segna il tempo mi chiedo un
avevo proprio idea di che cosa cazzo
servisse un orologio salve aveva meno
birra che non le fa bene alla pancia lo
dico parquet [ __ ] che testata di sismi
cosa narratore di questo livello è un
cestino
oddio che è successa l'orologio che ha
scritto aiuto sul fiore sullo specchio
mi fate accendere la luce per cortesia
non si accende niente va bene è il
livello più raccapricciante di è più vi
scrivo abbia mai fatto ve lo dico
sarò qui chi è che sarah quel già
inquietante avere un cestino che mi sta
parlando per fare non farmi kakà in mano
error o di quella [ __ ] ragazzi mi sono
caga tissimo perché avevo il volume al
massimo delle cuffie io mio tipo
stordito l'avrete ma una tisana non ve
la fate voi no ve lo chiedo voi avrete
sentito normale io ci sono stordito le
orecchie como letteralmente youtube i
questionari stephen jen cosa creator
non so chi sia stephen centro you tube
logo ok ma sapete caro tipo in
difficoltà seria ma se io è da questa
grave ma grave proprio tuffo su youtube
out by google
ok c'è chi ha più iscritti smart shop di
pipe and e quando hai creato sto livello
zio credo phillip high
gli apo iscritti ma che cazzo ne sky
those minecraft che tra l'altro anche
incontrato cartai sparkler e [ __ ]
che ne so quale di questi video ha più
view o questa è la domanda breaking
bolot workshop wrecking ball in che
hanno iniziato youtube 2004 2005 2005 il
cazzone neanche di youtube so niente chi
è il co fondatore di youtube e steward
butter file da steve chen fantastico che
culo in tedesco un quiz di youtube in
tedesco
welcome hands on dance è il claim
youtube quei frangenti sta per string 26
stile glam in canal l'estado notato vado
uil in tv squad line paola da hangar
paola paola paola mai paola brava paola
un cazzo proprio vice winterthur zh
briale julien cseo e mitra leo che
voglio andare su dirlo un bae va bene
non ci sono arrivate sentiva affanculo
vabbè dai fanno i miei livelli va capito
io banana cioè fare mi chiamo cristina
no tu sei io banana e sono una tua fan
che viene da top da tokyo
minchia beata te zia a christie's famo
cambio rai due va dove vado d'istinto
bello un livello pieno di significato fa
vj livello multiplo provalo se ti piace
botta 5 stelle non sentivo in politica
voto chi cazzo voglio io non me lo devi
venire di tu che cazzo devo votare e non
riesco a leggere fallisce in tv questo
livello l'ho fatto per te
spero che tu lo possa provare ti seguo
dagli inizi da quando non è t seconda
inizierà quando non è nessuno con meno
con meno di 1.000 iscritti ti ringrazio
per cui ti ringrazio per quanti sorrisi
mi hai dato in tutti questi anni e di
quante giornate mi hai trasformato con
la t maiuscola come transformers in
giornate piene di allegria grazie prego
zia prego ci riprova un miliardo di
volte non ci riesco comandate ma calmi
l'amato livello due torri e vabbè quanta
roba non vado in azienda l'hai fatto
infattibile e va bene va bene ho capito
grazie allo stesso valigie impossible
buona fortuna a un livello che
finalmente posso finire bello
meraviglioso ok mi piaceva
entra va bene ragazzi facciamo l'ultimo
perché nicchia genoa fa vj vicentini
impossibile al 99 per cento si può fare
lo zio la chiesa e poi in farsa
l'accordo ragazzi che un crollo vile
episodio è stato istruttivo anche oggi
giocare è perciò uno stimolo di andare a
cagare devi stare calmo e di 700 ragazzi
cosa se vi è piaciuto lasciate un
commento è un mi piace anche la pagina
di facebook del credito trascrizione io
vado a fare colazione se non se ne
volesse discutere ci rivediamo un
prossimo video bella ragazza